but first this weekend joe biden
introducing his climate team
who will aid john kerry in putting the
rest of the world first
and america last here's joe's new
climate czar gina mccarthy
climate change is not only a threat to
the planet
it is a threat to our health in our
well-being
it's a threat to people everywhere our
success
will require the engagement of every
community
every sector in our nation and every
country
in the world i can only imagine which
country she's willing to focus on
oh that's right she has a long history
of praising china
even saying back in 2013 that she's
impressed by them
and applauds their climate change
progress
it's not just what the administration
stands for but what they're getting
behind
just days after biden's inauguration the
world economic forum will officially
launch
their great reset agenda in davos
laura warned you about this last month
these biden globalists are trying to
force radical social
and economic change across the world at
your expense
joe biden's climate envoy john kerry is
already promising that the great reset
will happen
the notion of a reset uh is more
important than ever before
we're at the dawn of an extremely
exciting time i know joe biden
believes this it's not enough just to
rejoin paris
for the united states it's not enough
for us to just do the minimum of what
paris requires